but God's season 3 isn't just a
well-deserved send-off for the crew of
the Enterprise D it's also filled with
cameos from across the Star Trek
franchise unfortunately one fun favorite
character didn't make the cut here's why
warning spoilers ahead between his
premiering January 2020 and his finale
in April 2023 Star Trek Picard
referenced not just the pass of Jean-Luc
Picard but many chubzas of Star Trek
history this includes the 90s TV series
Star Trek Voyager wampigard season 2
Easter Egg featured a distinctive com
sound effect well familiar to Voyager
fans there's also an Easter egg in
Picard season 3 in which Picard recount
meeting a species of alien called the
herojan so when the alpha Advanced the
hunter had been turned into the prey a
Cadet even mentions Voyager protagonist
Amaral Catherine Janeway after all it
was her crew that made violent first
contact with the species in fact season
3 showrunner Terry matalis originally
intended for Admiral Janeway to appear
in the final season of Star Trek Picard
only for the show's producers to reject
the idea but Silas revealed his plans
for a Janeway Cameo during a Roundtable
discussion he said there were characters
I really wanted to see again in the
original finale script look it was a
giant movie that we were building on a
television time schedule the fact that
you saw what we saw was miraculous that
we pulled it off and nearly killed us
all we wanted Kate Mulgrew to be part of
seven of Nine's promotion during that
same Roundtable discussion Terry matalis
went into more detail about the ax
potential cameos ultimately a Star Trek
Picard line producer had final say over
the scope of season three's conclusion
the producer gave the thumbs down to
several Cameo ideas including an
appearance by Janeway matalis explained
they're all in the first script and then
your line producer says are you out of
your mind you can't afford these things
you are not avengers end game so they
got to go away and so those are our
regrets janeway's absence from Picard
isn't due to a lack of trying but rather
than ambition that the series budget was
unable to realize Janeway for what it's
worth is still actively a part of Star
Trek in its current Incarnation she
appears in animated form on both seasons
of Star Trek Prodigy a return for Jane
Wayne live action then may well still be
a possibility as the Star Trek franchise
continues Star Trek Picard first hints
at the possibility of an admiral Janeway
Cameo during the sixth episode of season
three it occurs in a scene where seven
of nine tells Jack Crusher about the USS
Voyager drawing a visit to the fleet
Museum underscoring a recollection of
her time on the ship is a brief musical
cue from the Star Trek Voyager theme the
USS Voyager
she made her name farther out than
any of those other relics had ever gone
after season six first premiered Jaime
actor Kate mogru herself reposted a clip
of this moment on Twitter with the
caption to the USS Voyager in response
to mulgrud's acknowledgment of the
Voyager shout outs several fans openly
wish for Janeway to make a Picard
appearance one Twitter fans said still
rooting for Janeway to be on Picard
meanwhile other users wrote that they
want to see Janeway make a return to
live action at some point and the Star
Trek franchise's future Picard or not
since Picard is over the kameo Terry
matalis originally had planned for
Janeway is an impossibility nevertheless
with interest in Janeway still high it's
entirely likely that there will
eventually be a live-action Star Trek
role for her moving forward
foreign